my name's spiraling I call my dad and I
literally say Dad did you see me come
out of mom's vagina and were there two
of me he starts laughing saying no like
no I was there there were not two of you
so I called my sister
um and I say do I have an identical twin
she's like oh and her gas I swear to God
I was like oh my God I do I have a twin
Chrissy Teigen was living out her Parent
Trap dreams over the weekend sharing the
mishap that led her to think she had an
identical twin sister
like like sisters
sisters Holly I like twins I have an
identical twin
Chrissy explains that she had an insane
24 hours after taking a DNA test to
learn more about her family history yeah
in a clip posted to Instagram Sunday
Chrissy says the results were shocking
the first thing that came up after I
found out that I was part neanderthal
was this
I have an identical twin
like that has to be a joke right I text
my doctor
that hello the whole thing is very
Lindsay Lohan Circa 1998 Annie and
Hallie separated at Birth only to beat
again at summer camp I think we should
switch places when Camp's over I'll go
back to London as you and you go back to
California as me what Annie we can pull
it off we're twins aren't we at this
point I'm like making excuses for my
whole life I'm like this is why I'm so
codependent because like my twin was
ripped away from me this is like I've
always felt something missing wild right
it's actually life-changing honestly
well not so much turns out Chrissy was
supposed to do the show Finding Your
Roots a show about diving into
celebrities ancestry but it never made
it to air my sister was like Chrissy no
remember when you were supposed to do
that show they had us all take DNA tests
and they put it under like secret names
so like the world couldn't tell my
identical twin was myself
I was matching myself it was a surprise
okay so Chrissy may not have an
identical twin but she is a mom to three
adorable kiddos with her hubby John
Legend it is fun giving so much to your
children and seeing them embrace it and
grow from how much love and kisses and
tension and affection they get it can be
so amazing the lovebirds share a
seven-year-old daughter Luna
five-year-old son miles and newborn
daughter Esty whom they welcomed in
January I just don't feel like anybody
regrets having too many kids I'm in awe
of what it takes to be a mother you know
not only the pregnancy but just all that
it takes to be a mother and what a gift
it is to all of us that we have
moms in our life that are willing to
to take that on
so that we can build our family yeah
[Music]
and leading up to all that ancestry
chaos at this point I'm spiraling the
proud mama shared a few Sweet Moments
with her little ones writing going into
the weekend with gratitude for my babies
my husband my friends and my team